ってわけで皆さんこんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
東海オンエアのて
なんでだよ！
今日はですね
てつや坊やがね
いつも通り変な車（ファンカーゴ）持ってきてくれたんで
実験的に
車（ファンカーゴ）の上でローション相撲してみたいと思います！
まぁ、なんで車の上でローション相撲しようと思ったかというと
普通のローション相撲はみんなやってるわけね
普通のローション相撲はつまらないと
車がへこむかへこまないかのスリルと
落ちてケガするかしないかの注意を
車に対する愛というかね
それも俺だけどね
やろう！
ぴゅぴゅぴゅ♪
べちゃ～（ローション垂らす音）
ﾌﾞﾘｭﾘｭｰ（ローションが切れる音）
滑らなかったら最悪だよ
いや、すべるでしょ、さすがに
あっ
どう？
きた！
ｗｗ
きたぞｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
きたぞｗｗ
塗ってと言わんばかりのヌルヌル感ｗ
こんなこと、多分、今後日本でする人いないと思いますわ
ｗｗｗ
車検通るのかな？
やめて、はじめしゃちょーの席やめてｗ
あぁやめなさいよもぉ～！
なんとかローションの準備が完成したので
早速戦っていこうと思います！
（ローションまみれのファンカーゴ）
やばい、手の付け所がない
バキッ（ファンカーゴのウィングが壊れる音）
うわ！
うそうそうそうそ？
やばい！やばいやばい！
ピロ～ン（ファンカーゴのウィングが落ちる音）
落ちちゃった
はっけよーい！
のこった！！
まじで勝ちにいくからね！
やばい！やばい×１３
てつやぁぁぁ！
うああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
俺の勝ちだ
ばか！
あああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ
出演
はじめしゃちょー
てつや（東海オンエア）
トヨタ　ファンカーゴ（東海オンエア）